ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends jack ted
sam and phil meet up for dinner after
they're done jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when phil sends his chair to jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then ted
and sam send their respective shares to
jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transaction cites
some issues at the bank that's when jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like litecoin ethereum
c cash and so on one reign supreme
bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have bill ted and
sam send jack two bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume phil ted and sam
have three bitcoins in reserve while
jack has five first phil sends two
bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block this record also
holds the number of bitcoins each of the
friends own so after phil's transaction
jack has seven bitcoins while phil has
one following this sam and ted send two
bitcoins to jack a new block is created
for each of these transactions these
blocks hold the transaction details as
well as how many bitcoins sam ted and
jack have in reserve these blocks are
linked to each other as each of them
takes reference from the previous one
for the number of bitcoins each brand
owns this chain of records or blocks is
called a ledger and this ledger is
shared among all the friends which acts
as a public distributed ledger this
forms the basis of blockchain so what
happens when phil has only one bitcoin
left and he tries to send two more
bitcoins to jack the transaction will
not go through this is because all his
friends have copies of the ledger and
it's clear that phil has only one
bitcoin left his friends will flag this
transaction as invalid a hacker will not
be able to alter the data in the
blockchain because each user has a copy
of the ledger the data within the blocks
are encrypted by complex algorithms all
of this is made possible with the help
of blockchain technology blockchain can
be described as a collection of records
linked with each other strongly
resistant to alteration and protected
using cryptography now let's have a
closer look at the bitcoin transaction
between jack and phil and find out how
it works every user in the bitcoin
network has two keys a public key and a
private key the public key is an address
that everyone in the network knows of
like an email address of a user the
private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of bitcoins he wants to send to
jack along with his and jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
encrypted using encryption algorithms
and using phil's unique private key this
is done to digitally sign the
transaction and to indicate that the
transactions came from fill this output
is now transmitted across the world
using jack's public key with this the
message or transaction can be decrypted
only by jack's private key which only
jack has knowledge of different
cryptocurrencies use different hashing
algorithms while bitcoin uses the
sha-256
algorithm ethereum which is also a
famous cryptocurrency uses one known as
ether
this transaction and several other
similar ones are taking place all around
the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem the minor
who solves this first adds the block to
the blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining
with this phil and jack's wallets are
updated just like every person in the
network who has completed a transaction
now that you know about blockchain and
its important concepts time for a small
quiz what is the concept of blockchain
that ensures data cannot be altered by
any of the users within the network a
public distributed ledger b
proof of work
c proof of stake d
hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below three lucky winners will
get amazon gift vouchers details are
mentioned in the description below let's
have a look at how walmart uses
blockchain to provide its customers with
better service walmart was facing
problems in delivering quality products
to its customers they were facing a high
return rate and large amounts of refunds
due to their products bad quality they
were unable to determine the point of
failure in the supply chain which
started from farm to storage to
transportation to processing all the way
to the customer then walmart adopted
blockchain technology with blockchain
the quality of the goods at each step
was permanently inscribed within a block
for example when a customer flags a
product as damaged it can be correctly
identified where the product got damaged
in the entire supply chain thus helping
walmart to identify the problem areas
and fixing them and this is just one of
several ways blockchain is used in real
life applications can you think of any
others let us know in the comments down
below that's all for now now what are
the current set of issues in today's
banking system in order to do any
transaction on a banking channel today
it costs a very high transaction fees so
suppose you want to do a transfer of
money from your account to someone's
else account through a banking channel
the bank might charge a fee for 200
transaction up to five dollars and this
receiver will end up receiving 195
which in percentage terms is a very high
percentage of transaction fee also as of
today there's a lot of scenarios people
end up doing double spending for example
over here the user has 800 dollars in
her account but she ends up sending
thousand dollars five hundred dollar
each to two users double spending is a
unique problem where digital money is
spent twice so what does it tend to do
is the user is able to make two
purchases with the amount which is less
than the purchase value so in this
scenario the lady was able to buy a
commodity worth more than eight hundred
dollars though she only had eight
hundred dollars in her account also the
banking systems are prone to hacking
hackers attack financial institutions
and gain unauthorized access to data
they can do transactions on your behalf
which you are not aware of or they can
do the transfer of money to some
illegitimate accounts in 2017 the number
of frauds in india through atm cards and
net banking total to
1785 each amounting to more than one
lakh rupee so if you see the current
banking system is prone to so many hacks
that it can amount to huge cost of money
now how bitcoin can solve these problems
now bitcoin is a decentralized system so
which allows you to do a value transfer
transaction at a lower transaction fee
as low as one dollar as compared to the
five dollar which the bank was charging
and at the end the receiver receives the
true value of the amount which was sent
by the sender bitcoin follows a
decentralized system where no third
party like governments banks or any
other financial intermediary is involved
during the transaction between the
sender and receiver thereby reducing the
cost of transaction drastically and that
is the primary objective of
cryptocurrencies or technologies like
blockchain which advocates the removal
of intermediaries now bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency that runs on blockchain
now how bitcoin solved the problem of
double spending double spending is
avoided through the basic structure of
blockchain which involves verification
of transactions so in the previous
example as we saw when the user
transferred 500
to the first person then she will not be
able to transfer the another 500
based on the basic validation of the
blockchain and we will see how suppose
you're trying to spend the same bitcoin
in a second transaction after the first
transaction has been confirmed the
saturn transaction will not get verified
and does become invalid and this will
happen because after the first
transaction has been confirmed your
balance will be verified in the second
transaction your address identity will
be validated and if suppose you are
trying to spend more than what the
balance you have the miners the
validators of the blockchain network
will discard that particular transaction
and will not add it to the main
blockchain network thereby double
spending becomes as good as impossible
in a blockchain each block is linked to
its previous block the transactions
become invalid for a specific bitcoin
which has already been spent so you
can't spend the bitcoin which you have
already spent public ledger a public
ledger records all bitcoin transactions
where it is accessible to everyone who
is associated with the system it is 100
transparent system any transaction
happening is visible on the public
ledger once a user joins the blockchain
network he gets a copy of all the
blockchain transaction since its
initiation or inception and the first
block in a blockchain is called the
genesis block though the public ledger
is accessible to everyone only the
user's address and the transaction
details are visible to the users on the
bitcoin network by looking at the
address you can't figure out to whom
this address belongs the identity is
secure of the address owner this keeps
blockchain safe from data tempering each
block on the blockchain is aware of who
is its previous block and this with
entire blockchain is created even if a
hacker tries to hack one block it would
have to change the entire subsequent
chain ahead of this block which will
require huge amount of computation power
for the hacker in order to make the
changes across all the blocks which is
next to impossible now what is
blockchain imagine two friends living
far away and would like to transfer
money using blockchain technology
blockchain is a decentralized system of
secure and trusted distributed databases
it's a distributed ledger which records
and shares the transaction details
across many nodes which are part of the
network so that the data is not modified
so each and every transaction which
happens on a blockchain network it
distributed across all the nodes on the
blockchain each and every participant
has the same copy of the ledger and it's
an immutable ledger once a record or a
transaction is registered it cannot be
modified blockchain was originally
introduced to timestamp digital
documents and prevent tampering of
records in simple terms a chain of
blocks that contain information
is is called blockchain now when a
transaction occurs its related
information is recorded into a block so
as you see a transaction initiated in
one corner of the globe can get
registered on the block and then that
block is being verified validated by the
miners of the public ledger and then
added to the main blockchain a block
contains aggregated transactions in a
single block which a miner has to
validate and in lieu of that the miner
gets rewarded now let's take a closer
look at what all are the components of a
block so whenever we talk about a
blockchain what is actually a block and
what it consists of now there are four
major components each block contains a
previous hash data data is nothing but
the aggregation of the transactions
which are aggregated in the block a
nuanced value and the hash of the block
itself now what is previous hash
previous hash is the attribute which is
connecting a block to its previous block
so the previous hash attribute consists
of the hash value of its previous block
data it consists the details of the
sender's address the receiver's address
and the transaction amount so basically
there could be multiple transactions
amongst multiple senders and receivers
so each block will consist n number of
transactions and each transaction will
have a sender's address a receiver
address and a transaction amount nonce
so basically the bitcoin uses a proof of
work algorithm and in order to execute
the algorithm nonce is a random value
used to vary the output of the hash
value so proof of work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain hash hash is like a digital
fingerprint it is the fingerprint of the
current block now where it takes an
input value of the previous hash the
data and the nonce and produces an
output value of fixed length so bitcoin
network uses sha 256 hashing algorithm
to generate a 256 bit length hash and
this is the output it looks something
like a hexadecimal value now what are
the features of blockchain a blockchain
is a decentralized public distributed
ledger that is used to record
transaction across many computers so
this is a sample transaction which you
are seeing these are set of three
transactions a transferring money to b b
to c and c to b a distributed ledger is
a database that is shared among all the
users who are part of the blockchain
network the transactions are accessed
and verified by users associated to the
bitcoin network thereby making it less
prone to cyber attack it is actually
enclosed within all the participants who
are part of the network now let's take
an example where these bitcoin users are
transferring money so here we have
example like bella is trying to transfer
money to john john is trying to transfer
money to elsa and elsa is trying to
transfer money to jack so these are the
three transactions which are to be
initiated now suppose these transactions
were being happening on a central ledger
and it gets corrupted so there is a
chance of the data getting tampered to
solve this problem a public distributed
ledger plays a vital role now it ensures
that users part of the cycle have a copy
of the transaction details each user
will have a copy of each transaction
bella john elsa jack they all have the
same ledger and this is what is called
as distributed ledger everyone is having
the same copy now in case one of the
users like elsa misplaces her
transaction detail she can easily be
corrected by the other participants
because they have the golden copy the
correct copy or if either of them
attempts to alter the record the
alternate transaction copies with the
other users will negate the alteration
because they will see that amongst all
the participants only one participant is
having a different copy they will negate
the copy of the user and they will
rectify it encryption blockchain
eliminates unauthorized access by using
cryptographic algorithm
sha-256 to ensure that the blocks are
kept secure so sha-256 is the
cryptographic algorithm which is used
each user in the blockchain has their
own keys so any user which on boards a
typical blockchain network is always
provided with two set of keys one is
private one is public private key is
known only to the sender also it is used
to confirm if the origin of the
transaction is legitimate public key it
is also used to uniquely identify the
user but it is shared by the sender with
every transaction it floats on the
blockchain network and we will see how
now let's take a look at a typical
transaction verification process suppose
a sender wants to send a message he will
pass the message through the hash
function and generate a hash value of
the message now after the hash value is
being created it is passed through a
signature algorithm and with the private
key a digitally signed document is
created now the transaction message
original message the digitally signed
document and the public key are
transmitted to the receiver now at the
receiver end the transaction message is
passed through a hash function to get a
hash value and that hash value is
compared with the hash value obtained by
passing the digital signature and public
key through a verification function and
then both the values are compared now
let's see how the hash function works
the hash function creates a unique
digital fingerprint of data you pass the
message to the hashing function and
generates a hash value this hash value
is called a digital print it has a very
unique property any hashing function is
a one way function it cannot be reversed
you cannot decode the original value
from the hashed value it is a one way
encryption so here are some examples
whatever be the size of the input data
the hash value is always of 256 bit
length and we will take a look at the
demo at the end of this session where
i'll show you how to generate a hash
value using sha-256 now let's consider
an example of gmail using hashing
algorithm whenever you are entering the
username and password that password is
never directly persisted in any of the
gmail database it is persisted using
hashing function so once you have
created your password and again once you
log in your password is again passed to
the hashing function and compared with
the hash value persisted in the database
and once both these hash value matches
then only you are allowed to log in so
every time you log into gmail your
password is hashed into a value and
compared against the one stored in the
database the hash values match with the
one in database and then the inbox is
displayed on your screen now let's take
a look of what is the proof of work
algorithm proof of work is a method to
validate transactions in a blockchain
network by solving a complex
mathematical puzzle and this whole
process is called mining finding the
nonce value is the mathematical puzzle
that users or miners need to solve in
the bitcoin network so it takes huge
amount of computational power and
resources of the miner in order to find
out that nuance value users trying to
solve the puzzle are called miners the
puzzle is solved by determining a nonce
that generates a hash value and results
an output lesser than a target so in any
proof of work algorithm there is always
a target which is predefined for a block
the miner has to use the nonce in order
to generate a hash which has to be less
than the target miners verify
transactions within a block and adds the
block to the blockchain when they have
confirmed and verified the transaction
with proof of work miners compete
against each other to solve the
mathematical puzzle the first miner who
solves the puzzle is rewarded and when a
block is solved the transactions
contained in a block are also considered
valid and the bitcoins associated with
the transactions then get deducted from
the originator or the sender and moves
to the receiver now let's see how proof
of work works so let's take a look at
the block and its components the
previous block hash it stores the hash
value of the previous block of the
blockchain data it contains the list of
all the transactions which have been
aggregated in the block nonce is the
random value which is used to generate a
hash value less than the target and hash
is the digital signature of the block
itself the hash is generated using a
hashing function called
sha-256 now using the nonce when the
hash is generated if its output is less
than the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved the block is
considered to be validated if not then
the miner increments the nonce by value
1 and then again rehashes generate a
hash and goes through the cyclic process
till the time it is not able to generate
a hash less than the target in
blockchain the target is adjusted every
two zero one six blocks which is
approximately every 14 days the average
time of block formation is 10 minutes
and the difficulty target of the puzzle
increases or decreases depending on the
time it takes to mine the blocks so it
is the inbuilt network which is
generating the target for the puzzle to
get solved and it fluctuates the
difficulty based on the time it takes to
mind block proof of work is hard to
produce but very easy for binders to
verify so point to be noted here is once
the block is hashed the remaining miners
are supposed to validate the work which
one miner has done but they are not
required to find the nonce again so
basically the miner who's supposed to
earn the bitcoin has done the hard work
but the others miners on the network
just have to verify his validation in
blockchain when miners use their
resources time money electricity etc to
validate a new transaction and record
them on the public ledger they are given
a reward now that reward is in bitcoins
itself which as of today stands at 12.5
bitcoins and to add there is no other
way that the bitcoins can be generated
in a bitcoin network it is only through
mining now the bitcoin network
internally halves the reward after every
21k blocks which is approximately every
four years so now subsequently whenever
the time period will end the mining
reward will get reduced to 6.25 btc now
let's take a look at a demo now as i
said this is a demo to showcase how to
generate a sha-256 hash using a input
value so whatever input i have the hash
which is generated it is of 256 bytes
even if i add a new value it will again
only generate a 256 bit length hash
now let's take a look at a typical
blockchain structure we have a block
over here which has one transaction
added to it now this is orange in color
because it has not been mined and i can
only add a subsequent block to it once
it is mined now as this is the first
block in this particular blockchain the
previous hash value of this block is all
zeros and it is called as a genesis
block now as i have mined this block the
hash which is the digital signature of
this block itself has been generated and
i can now add a block primary thing
which to be noted over here is that the
previous hash value of this new block is
the hash value of the previous block it
has two transactions aggregated in it
and i can again mine it and now the hash
of this block has been generated so this
highlights the typical data structure of
a blockchain and how blocks are linking
themselves to each other now let's take
a look of a typical transaction which
happens over a blockchain now i want to
send money from wallet one to wallet two
and i want to send one dollar there is a
transaction fee of point one dollar
associated with this transaction now as
i have initiated that transaction wallet
one has been deducted as 1.1 dollar and
it is a pending transaction this
transaction is waiting to be mined so i
can choose any of the miners to do this
transaction the pending transaction is
done and now block 2 if you see has been
added the previous hash value of this
block is 0 0 a 9 is the hash value of
block 1. another thing to be noted the
value of the amount in wallet 2 has also
got incremented by one done again we can
try another transaction transferring one
dollar again from wallet one to wallet
three and
say from wallet two to wallet three i
have done a transaction it is pending it
can be mined and block three has got
added now what are the key takeaways
today we learned what are the current
issues in the banking system and how
bitcoin solved them what is blockchain
features of blockchain and the demo of
the features which we have seen
hyperledger
hyperledger is an open source
collaborative effort created to advance
cross-industry blockchain technologies
it is a global collaboration hosted by
the linux foundation including leaders
in finance
banking internet of things
supply chains manufacturing and
technology
it is a framework to create deploy
and maintain blockchains for businesses
that ensure accountability transparency
and trust among business partners
as a result hyperledger makes business
networks and transactions more efficient
concept of hyperledger now before i tell
what hyperledger is
let me tell you what hyperledger isn't
hyperledger isn't a blockchain a company
or a cryptocurrency
hyperledger is a software used to create
one's own personalized blockchain
service
it is basically a project within the
linux foundation just like several other
projects under them which include nodejs
all join
drone code and akumos
since it is open source people across
the globe can come and help develop and
grow the platform
restrictions in public blockchain with a
goal in mind to develop an
enterprise-based blockchain platform
developers started testing interactions
between applications and secure
blockchains and realized that public
blockchains require each peer to
validate transactions and run consensus
this is a major challenge when it comes
to scalability
moreover the transaction confidentiality
and privacy was also getting lost as
every node in the network was receiving
a copy of the ledger
private and confidential contracts
let's consider an example
a certain bank is giving better
privileges to its premium customers for
instance in credit cards
thus if i'm a premium customer of the
bank and have been banking with them for
quite some time then it will give me a
better offer on credit cards or will
give me a loan at discounted rates
these things are common in the banking
world
however if these banks start using
public blockchains which have complete
transparency disparity like these will
become evident
moreover there is an issue with regards
to competition
all banks are competing with each other
in order to create a better place for
themselves in the market
thus they want their confidential
information about transactions and other
operations to stay completely
confidential
this won't be possible in a public
blockchain like ethereum which stores
all smart contracts on public ledgers
this is where platforms like hyper
ledger come into the picture which
permits permissioned and private
transactions and it is highly scalable
as a platform
solution to the restrictions
on hyperledger network only parties
directly related to the transaction deal
are updated on the ledger thus
maintaining privacy and confidentiality
hyperledger primarily leverages the
concept of channels to ensure privacy
and confidentiality
a channel is basically a virtual
blockchain network which sits atop a
physical blockchain network and has its
own access rules
they employ their own mechanism for
transaction ordering and thus ensures
scalability thereby permitting effective
ordering along with the separation of
data in the above example when john and
cat are conducting a transaction a
private channel between them serves as a
method of interaction
the smart contract can thus be viewed by
only these two parties and the network's
endorsement policy verifies their
membership with the network to ensure
privacy thus the transaction is secured
and private and confidential
hyperledger transaction
in the above example john is initiating
a transaction to send a message to cat
let's assume that we have a state in the
ledger named as message denoting the
last message that had been sent and its
store as a key value pair in peer of
organization
now john has decided to send a new
message to cat and submit a request to
the node.js backend from the message
dashboard the node.js
sdk client takes this new proposed state
and sends a proposal to all the
endorsing peers of the organization as
per the endorsing policy defined in the
channel configuration
as well as confining to the membership
services
this includes a proposal request to
invoke the corresponding function
described in the chain code
the message thus gets verified by the
orderer and finally gets committed to
the couchdb thus confirming the
transaction
linux family
hyperledger is a part of the umbrella
project under linux foundation where a
community of developers work on open
source projects
linux foundation provides infrastructure
services events
training and financial resources for
creating sustainable open source
ecosystems
linux foundation is known for its open
source projects
hyperledger is a consortium of
organizations it's not a blockchain
platform with hyperledger there are
different blockchain projects
the original code for these projects was
submitted by various companies like ibm
intel etc
linux then made these codes open source
to invite the entire community to work
together and contribute to the codes
the vision was to create an enterprise
level blockchain platform hyperledger
projects
hyperledger umbrella strategy
hyperledger nurtures a lot of blockchain
frameworks and technologies under the
umbrella strategy some of the well-known
projects under hyperledger are as
follows
sawtooth lake
hyperledger sawtooth is a blockchain
platform implementation which builds
deploys and runs distributed ledgers it
is a modular platform which provides a
digital record without a central
authority or implementation
it is primarily used for supply chain
networks
fabric
hyperledger fabrics framework was
contributed by ibm
fabric works as a foundation for
developing applications with a modular
architecture the framework utilizes
container technology to host smart
contracts chain code comprising the
system's application logic one of the
examples where it is used is fishing
industry to track the supply chain of
fishes
burrow
hyperledger burrow hosted by the linux
foundation is a blockchain framework
implementation
the framework was contributed by monax
and co-sponsored by intel
burrow is a permission smart contract
application engine partially developed
in accordance to the specifications of
ethereum virtual machine evm
it is used to run ethereum smart
contracts
eroja
hyper ledger eroja hosted by the linux
foundation is another blockchain
platform implementation
the framework was contributed by sora
mitsu
hitachi ntt data in kulu
written in c plus plus hyperledger eroja
incorporates a unique algorithm on
chain-based byzantine fault tolerant
consensus
it provides a small set of fast commands
and queries covering most common
operations for the digital asset and
identity management
it can be used in mobile application
organization
indie
hyper ledger indie is a distributed
ledger and utility library built for
decentralized identity
the distributed ledger provides tools
libraries and reusable components to
create and use independent digital
identities based on blockchains they are
inoperable across administrative
applications domains and any other silo
it is used as a decentralized identity
database
sawtooth
hyperledger sawtooth is a blockchain
platform built for enterprise use where
the design focuses on maintaining the
safety of smart contracts and the
ledgers are kept distributed
sawtooth offers a simplified platform
for blockchain application development
by separating the application domain at
the core system level
application developers could opt for a
language of their choice to write smart
contracts logic
following are some of the key features
of sawtooth
application layer in core system
separation
parallel transaction execution pluggable
consensus algorithm
private networks with sawtooth
permissioning features
ethereum contract compatible with seth
event system
hyperledger architecture hyperledger
blockchain network participants
following are the different participants
within hyperledger blockchain
blockchain user
a blockchain user performs transaction
on the network
the user can invoke a function from the
chain code in order to send the
instruction message to the underlying
network which can then process the
transaction
certificate authority
the certificate authority ensures that
only certain restricted parties can be a
part of the business network on
hyperledger they access security
certifications in order to determine the
parties who have required privileges to
be an actor on a network
traditional database it is a standard
database which is used to store data
traditional processing platform
it stores access to the logical code
written which is used to run the network
as per the design
blockchain development network
it operates the blockchain network which
enables the execution of smart contracts
chain code as well as various
transactions that take place between the
participants which are part of the
network
blockchain developer
a developer develops applications on the
blockchain using chain code currently
hyperledger fabric supports node.js
java and golang languages to write such
chain codes
regulator
regulator runs oversight to ensure that
the platform is operating without any
bias
hyperledger architecture
following are three main components of
hyperledger
membership service
it is a set of cryptographic materials
certificates that defines organization
by itself every peer and orderer needs
this type of certificate
this certificate has some common
property by which we decide whether the
peer and the orderer belongs to the same
organization or not
a peer which is a part of the same msp
can communicate with each other a peer
from other organizations cannot be
allowed to communicate with each other
blockchain and transaction layer
this layer constitutes the core code of
the blockchain it comprises of consensus
algorithm which is required to make the
final decision on the state of every
transaction it also contains the
distributed ledger and ledger storage
which stores the entire history of the
transactions and the last known states
lastly we have the pdp protocol which is
used for communication between different
nodes on the network
chain code it is the logical programming
layer which consists of the business
logic required to run an operation on
the hyperledger permissioned blockchain
and its consensus model permissioned
blockchain maintains an access control
layer and allows certain actions to be
performed only by a few identifiable
participants it is also called private
blockchain
following are the properties specific to
permissioned blockchains
it has legally accountable validators
it is suitable for off-chain assets they
can be used as an i.t tool for
settlement and clearing examples include
ripple which determines roles for a
select number of participants who can
act as transaction validators on their
network
such blockchains are also popular among
industry level enterprises and
businesses for which security identity
and role definition are important
permissioned versus permissionless
blockchain
let us see some differences between a
permissioned and a permissionless
blockchain
one in regards to access a permissioned
blockchain only allows pre-approved
members to access the network and make
transactions to it whereas a
permissionless blockchain allows anyone
to be a part of the network as it is
completely open and transparent
two
permissioned blockchain are faster than
permissionless blockchain when it comes
to performance as they have less number
of participants in the network three
permissioned blockchain use different
types of consensus algorithms like pbft
proof of stake and more usually
permissionless blockchains rely on proof
of work
four the transaction cost in a
permissioned blockchain is lower than
that of a permissionless blockchain
five in regards to stability
permissioned blockchain are considered
more stable compared to permissionless
blockchains as the former have a better
governance due to known parties which
are a part of the network
six in a permissionless blockchain all
participants have the same level of
access whereas a permissioned blockchain
provides full access only to the members
which are registered to be a part of the
business network
7.
permissionless blockchains work in a
peer-to-peer fashion relying solely on
consensus algorithms to create a trusted
environment however permissioned
blockchains have trusted members as part
of the network which enhances the trust
on the network consensus and its
interaction with architectural layers
consensus
consensus is the process by which a
network of nodes validates the block of
transactions and provide a guaranteed
ordering of transactions and validating
those block of transactions that need to
be committed to the ledger consensus
must ensure the following in the network
confirms the correctness of all
transactions in a proposed block
according to endorsement and consensus
policies
agrees on order and correctness and
hints on the results of execution
depends on smart contract layer to
verify correctness of an ordered set of
transactions in a block hyperledger
makes use of the permissioned voting
base consensus from the pool of the
other consensus named the lottery-based
consensus
consensus properties
consensus must satisfy two properties to
guarantee agreement among nodes
safety and liveness
safety means that each node is
guaranteed the same sequence of inputs
and results in the same output on each
node
the algorithm must behave identical to a
single node system that executes each
transaction atomically one at a time
liveness means that each non-faulty node
will eventually receive every submitted
transaction assuming that communication
does not fail
activities performed to reach consensus
hyperledger frameworks reach consensus
by performing two activities
transaction ordering transaction
validation
by logically separating these activities
we ensure that any hyperledger framework
can work with any hyperledger consensus
module
the first step of the consensus process
flow is receiving the transactions from
the client application
consensus depends on an ordering service
to order transactions
transaction order enables
confidentiality of the transactions
it also increases the efficiency of the
transactions
to validate transactions consensus
depends on the smart contract layer
because it contains the business logic
behind what makes a transaction valid
transaction validation contains business
logic to make the transaction valid
it also ensures the confirmation of
policies and contracts specified for the
transaction
then it also checks for syntax and logic
errors
consensus model for permissioned
blockchain
consensus in hyperledger fabric as seen
in the image above is broken out into
three phases
endorsement ordering and validation
endorsement is driven by policy e.g m
out of n signatures upon which
participants endorse a transaction
ordering phase accepts the endorsed
transactions and agrees to the order to
be committed on the ledger
validation takes a block of ordered
transactions and validates the
correctness of the results including
checking endorsement policy and double
spending
as soon as a new transaction is created
it is sent to the endorsement peer to
generate a read write pair the read
write pair from every endorser is then
sent to the order which orders the same
and generates a block based on consensus
the ordered block is then sent to the
validator to update the couch db with
the most recent state
api and network topology in hyperledger
api it enables clients and applications
to interface to the blockchains
hyperledger supports the following types
of apis
admin apis
this class creates an administration
connection to a hyperledger composer
runtime the connection can then be used
to
deploy business network definitions
business network definitions
update business network definitions
send a ping message to the runtime to
ensure it is running and correctly
configured
story connection profile document in the
connection profile store
common apis
they are used to obtain information
about the connected networks
this information can include business
network
metadata enum declaration and many more
runtime apis
these are used to perform all
transaction operations like running a
query managing assets and more
network topology
network topology is a technical
infrastructure that provides smart
contract services and ledger to
applications
listed below are the components of
network topology
ledger
a ledger consists of two distinct parts
a blockchain and the state database
unlike other ledgers blockchains are
immutable in contrast the world state is
a database containing the current value
of the set of key value pairs that have
been added modified or deleted by the
set of validated and committed
transactions in the blockchain
smart contract a smart contract is a
code that is invoked by a client
application external to the blockchain
network it manages access and
modifications to a set of key value
pairs in the world state
in hyperledger fabric smart contracts
are referred to as a chain code peer
nodes
it is a network entity that maintains a
ledger and runs chain code containers in
order to perform read write operations
to the ledger
peers are owned and maintained by
members
ordering service it is a defined
collective of nodes that orders
transactions into a block
the ordering service exists independent
of the peer processes and orders
transactions on a first come first
served basis for all channels on the
network
channels
a channel is a private blockchain
overlay which allows for data isolation
and confidentiality
a channel specific ledger is shared
across the peers in the channel and
transacting parties must be properly
authenticated to a channel in order to
interact with it fabric certificate
authorities hyperledger fabric ca is the
default certificate authority component
which issues pki-based certificates to
network member organizations and their
users
the ca issues one root certificate to
each member and one enrollment
certificate to each authorized user
steps to create a hyperledger network
following steps should be followed to
create a hyperledger network
step one create a network
the network is created from the
definition of the consortium including
its clients peers
channels and ordering service
the ordering service is the
administration point for the network
because it contains the configuration
for the channel within the network
step 2 define a consortium a consortium
is comprised of two or more
organizations on the network
consortiums are defined by organizations
that have a need for transacting
business with one another and they must
agree to the policies that govern the
network
step 3 create a channel for consortium a
channel is a means of communication used
to connect the components of the network
and or the member client applications
4
join peers to channels
peers are joined to channels by the
organizations that own them and there
can be multiple pure nodes on channels
within the network
step 5 install smart contracts
smart contract chain code must be
installed and instantiated on a peer in
order for a client application to be
able to invoke the smart contract
step six optimize the network
while there is no theoretical limit on
how big a network can get
as the network grows it is important to
consider design choices that will help
optimize network throughput stability
and resilience
step 7
add another consortium definition
as consortia are defined and is added to
the existing channel we must update the
channel configuration by sending a
channel configuration update transaction
to the ordering service
step 8 add a new channel
organizations are what form and join
channels and channel configurations can
be amended to add organizations as the
network grows when adding a new channel
to the network channel policies remain
separate from other channels configured
on the same network
step nine add peer and join it to
multiple channels
you can continue adding new peers and
connect them to several channels within
the network
network topology the diagram above shows
a fabric network with the following
configuration
there is a fabric network in
with network policy np1
and ordering service o
channel c1 is governed by channel policy
cp1
channel c1 has been established by
consortium rarb
channel c1 is managed by ordering
service o and peers p1 and p2 and client
applications a1 and a2 have been granted
permission to transact on c1
client application a1 is owned by
organization ra
certificate authority ca1 serves
organization ra
pure p2 maintains ledger l1 associated
with channel c1 and l2 associated with
c2
prp2 makes use of chain code s4 and s5
the order nodes of ordering service o
are owned by organization rd who is a
blockchain developer
a blockchain developer is a person who
is responsible for developing and hence
enhancing blockchain related
applications famously known as dapps
smart contracts architecture and
protocols
for those who don't know what blockchain
is
blockchain is a system of recording
details of transactions in a block
taking place in the blockchain network
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change or hack
which means they are immutable
a blockchain is essentially a digital
public ledger of transactions that is
copied and distributed across the entire
network of computer systems on the
blockchain
basically blockchain developers enable
secure digital transactions by creating
systems and applications to record and
store blockchain data and prevent
external changes or hacks
that brings us to what are the types of
blockchain developers
there are two types of blockchain
developers
core blockchain developers and
blockchain software developers
each type has its specific type of role
let's go through them in more detail
the core blockchain developers designed
the protocols required to run a
blockchain solution successfully which
means they are majorly responsible for
the architecture development of
blockchain
are also responsible for designing
consensus protocols and making
high-level decisions
blockchain software developers
develop and implement the blockchain
using the designs and solutions created
by the core blockchain developers
they are majorly responsible for
designing and implementing smart
contracts and developing decentralized
applications or dapps
now let's understand what are the
technical skills required to become a
blockchain developer to become a
blockchain developer you need to have a
specific set of technical skills let's
take a look at them
understanding blockchain architecture
for starters you should have a complete
understanding of blockchain technology
its architecture how it works and its
critical concepts like hash functions
distributed ledger technology and
consensus protocols
next data structure and coding
data structures and coding are
considered the most basic and essential
skills required to be a fine developer
it is a must-have skill to become a
blockchain developer as it enhances your
ability to play and configure blockchain
according to your requirements
development of smart contracts
smart contracts is the most vital part
of blockchain technology the programming
language solidity is used to create
smart contracts
ethereum is the best example for smart
contracts it helps you set up the
business and develop and deploy dabs
using smart contracts
and at last basic knowledge of
cryptography
blockchain secures its data by using
highly effective cryptography algorithms
cryptography helps you implement dabs
and other blockchain services
now we have covered the technical skills
required to become a blockchain
developer let's explore the roles and
responsibilities of a blockchain
developer
both core blockchain developer and
blockchain software developer have
different roles and responsibilities
first we will discuss the roles and
responsibilities of code blockchain
developer
core blockchain developer understand and
implement the features and
functionalities of blockchain
they design protocols and consensus
protocols for blockchain networks
they create solutions for providing
security to the data stored in the
blockchain network
and then make sure that the blockchain
network functions smoothly and securely
now blockchain software developer design
and implement smart contracts
they develop and deploy decentralized
application or dabs as per the
requirements
also they look after the integration
with other applications and services
now let's dive down and explore the
companies hiring blockchain developers
there is a massive demand for blockchain
developers and if you know your skills
well you will surely get a good start
with your career as blockchain developer
joining a programmers community and
working on real projects will help you
learn grow and upskill yourself
according to 2021 scienceof a software
development company ripple labs in
corporation an american technology
company that deals with the ripple
payment
leeway herds a software development
company for startup at enterprises
chroma way a blockchain technology
company
open ledger a decentralized financial
platform used to convert bitcoins to
smart coins
and intellect soft a company specialized
in providing software products and
integrated solutions are a few top
companies who hired blockchain
developers to work on blockchain
technology
now that we know about the demand of
blockchain developers worldwide let's
figure out the average salary of a
blockchain developer in both the usa and
india
in the usa the average salary of
blockchain developer is over 157
thousand dollars per year
and in india it ranges from 5 lakh
rupees 30 lakh rupees per year
so this is all about who is a blockchain
developer
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important do
let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on who is a
blockchain developer and learn something
new from it if you like this video then
please do hit the like button
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more updates and videos from simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here